so the the big subject uh
we wanted to talk about this week was
born of of course russia's invasion of
ukraine which is horrendous and tragic
uh there were some comments that we were
too glib about it um because we have
casual conversations i want to be very
clear the situation's [ __ ] up it's
dark it breaks my heart
i'm not okay with this it's not casual
to talk about world war three
you and i have a tendency to
try to see the positive things in life
and laugh um it's how we cope i'm sorry
if people were offended by that i mean
that's the type of thing i'm i don't
like to apologize too often for internet
comments but that's a real one to me
sorry
i mean i i agree yeah i mean like every
day you wake up and you uh zoom in and
you see the
the the death and the strife and the
refugees it's heartbreaking it's awful
so to that point
so as someone who whose family
immigrated this country the the sense of
america as being a good place i mean
there's this idea of american
exceptionalism where everyone's like
america is a special place in the world
and i think uh you know
uh shining city on a hill standing on a
hill yeah was that
reagan that was reagan yeah so so a
shining city on a hill uh and then in in
during reagan you had the berlin wall
come down you had the ussr
uh lose a cold war right and so there
was this arc of america as this uh force
for good and developing democracy there
was this idea
wow was this incredibly positive but
they called a period like the end of
history because they said at this point
democracy
and uh globalized economy were going to
win
and then that was that
what a what a happy positive moment that
was
uh now things have kind of rebounded
um because
you've had
authoritarian countries
come up and demonstrate that there are
different models of uh competitiveness
and success most prominently china
there was like a long period of time
when america thought hey if we can just
get
commerce in there then they're going to
liberalize they're going to wind up
democratizing because you can't have
this thriving chinese middle class
buying washing machines and watching
western movies who are uh going to
accept a repressive regime of course
that was all wrong like that it turns
out that they're perfectly happy with
um not perfectly happy i mean i don't
mean to say that but that that like you
know there hasn't been like a real
contest
of um
ideas within china in terms of democracy
versus uh authoritarianism
so the the there was an arc throughout
the 80s certainly under reagan and bush
and then i would i would argue it
persisted through the 90s that america
was this
exceptional democracy uh and then
there's been this increased questioning
of that there's been like an increased
questioning of conventional histories
um saying that uh you know like and
again
america
does have massive moral stains
uh on its uh on itself um throughout its
history but i
i still
feel like this should be a time for a
re-inspection
of both america's place in the world and
whether one would accept that america
despite its failings is a force
for
improving people's lives
uh
everywhere around the world hopefully um
and also that there are massive
opportunities for us to improve people's
lives here and now
you know within our borders
uh
that there's like a positivity you know
it's like that this sense if you lose
the faith that america will do the right
thing then you lose something very very
enormous and one of the things that i
try to do
um and and people you know sometimes you
know said like oh that this approach
won't work or whatnot but i think you'll
appreciate this having started a
non-profit
is you
you believe
that someone's going to help and then
you kind of present that belief to them
and then sometimes they help
yeah you know what i mean yep like i i
feel that about america where it's like
you believe america will help whether
it's
help the the ukrainian people
uh end this war and and uh convinced
putin that this war was deeply profane
and unjust
or whether it's helping americans live a
better life
where you say look uh you know there is
no reason why we need to have
this level of scarcity and deprivation
and poverty in the richest country in
the history of the world like we can
actually
make those changes
uh so the this is something that um
i i believe in my heart first that this
is a good country and that the people
are good um but i also think it's a
better way to go because it's more
likely to lead to what you want
it's more likely to lead to good places
right let me see this real quick come on
i'm going to do what you've done to me a
number of times i'm going to quote
myself
and this is actually my real medic
because i'm going to quote
look at this he's quoting a book that
has not yet been published but that you
can buy you can buy right now i'm going
to quote myself quoting
someone else when you're young you think
the cavalry is coming to save us
when you grow up you realize that you
are the cavalry
quote andrew yang i don't know where you
got that quote from but you're my source
on this
and
it's kind of what you're saying it's
like
america
by like or is the bill clinton quote you
said there's nothing
wrong with america that can't be fixed
about with what's right about america
yeah there's nothing wrong with america
that can't be fixed with what's right
about america and theoretically america
is set up to bring the cavalry
that is what it's set up to do
[Music]
you